no no no no no fake it don't fake it I
know it's a long night
congratulations
what would you say is the
oh I couldn't say
you came too hard with the first
question
what's the meaning of life Eddie it's
like what the [ __ ]
I think comedy is just fine you know I
think you know there's a lot of funny
people out there and uh it's actually a
bigger you got the bigger platform to do
comedy and comedy is just fine
feel today with people over here
um as we approach Black History Month I
was wondering if you have a living
legend that you could talk about what
they mean to you a living living legend
living legend
do I have a living legend that's uh most
of them the legends that I look up to
are all the dead you know but the
legends
and my my the number one Legend of all
time for me is Muhammad Ali
so so that's what my head went to so I I
was like who's like Muhammad Ali around
now for man I'm like nobody is my hero
and the legend of my life is Muhammad
Ali
in this black history month
is that it okay unfortunately that's the
last question oh okay cool
one last question
like to see you go back and host
Saturday Night Live you did such a such
an awesome job last time you were on I
think we went in before it uh yeah I did
one
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely looking
forward to going back
I'm looking forward to going back and
doing it yeah we would have might have
did it this last year but we were
working
on a movie
but absolutely we'll go back and do it
again
and so happy that I did
thanks for coming back to SN oh here oh
yeah
but they got to warm it up y'all got to
tell somebody y'all gotta that room is
so cold
it's so cold
I mentioned what
the slack
no I haven't but I love both of them
[Applause]
[Music]